coup la sphère grégory la chambre
d'accusation de dijon ordonne un
supplément d'information avait le choix
entre trois solutions renvoi en cour
d'assises et c'était le procès à l'autre
extrémité si j'ose dire le non lieu et
christine villemin était innocenté ou le
supplément d'information alors m garot
le défenseur du couple villemin a
l'intention
il vient de le dire de demander la mise
en liberté de jean marie villemin
nous retrouvons tout de suite à dijon
isabelle bechler président de la chambre
d'accusation monsieur maurice simon
annulés aujourd'hui 450 pages sur les
3500 que compte dossier wilm nuit procès
verbaux établis par le juge lambert ont
été purement et simplement annulée pour
vice de forme pas de non-lieu donc pour
christine villemin
mais un vrai examen des charges qui
pèsent contre elle la chambre
d'accusation a fait le toilettage du
dossier en ce sens qu'elle a annulé un
certain nombre de pièces et d'autre part
qu'elle a retenu à l'encontre de
l'inculpé une dizaine de charges que
nous n'avons jamais c'est celle de m au
gonflant ce lourd désaveu au travail
d'instruction du juge lambert nommé
pourtant pas un terme à l'inculpation
christine villemin
elle est toujours accusé d'avoir tué son
enfant
pour nous c'est pareil doucement aux
aimants s'achemine vers la solution que
nous espérons et que nous avons toujours
espéré et qui nous paraît être celle de
la justice à savoir le non lieu pour
madame christine villemin c'est parce
que le sort de jean marie villemin est
lié à celui de son épouse aujourd'hui
même dans cette journée nous allons
déposer une demande de mise en liberté
dans l'intérêt de jean marie villemin
qui est détenu depuis le 29 mars 1985 ce
qui fait un peu plus de deux années
une nouvelle phase de l'instruction
reprend donc mené par le président de la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
dit lui même le président maurice simon
a même repoussé son départ la retraite
de quelques mois pour pouvoir mener à
son terme le 2 c'est grégory autres